Rebecca starts off this hour in Fargo
North Dakota hi Rebecca how are you I'm
good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up so I'm just calling so
I could get your advice on a decision
that my husband and I are deciding to
make to get out of debt so last year
around this time my husband I decided
that he was going to take a job as a
civilian contract worker over in
Afghanistan as a paramedic and we were
planning on just having him do it for a
year but that year mark has come and we
didn't make the progress that we were
hoping on our debt we're currently in
baby step two why I'm so worried what
why did you not make the progress you
were hoping I am a special ed teacher
and so last May my contract was not
renewed for the next school year and I
was having a hard time finding another
job so we kind of went a year on just
his income because I was having
struggling to find a job as a teacher
where we were living gotcha
how much debt do you guys have not
counting your own currently we have
eighty thousand left yeah what did you
start with we started with what were we
at 130 actually paid off fifty thousand
with him being overseas for a year yes
part of that was we sold his truck and
we sold a couple things to pay off that
debt Wow so you make much progress at
all as a result in being overseas
correct
hmm how does he make what was that what
does he make currently he makes ninety
five thousand okay and I'll be starting
work this fall I got a job as a special
ed teacher and I'll be making thirty
eight thousand to add to his ninety five
thousand and so we were looking at
having him stay until December
with my added income and then we're also
going to be selling our house because
we're moving to a new area will be
renting so the profit that we make off
of our house selling our house can be
throwing at our debt as well but the
issue that were I'm struggling with is I
guess more on a personal level where I'm
getting a lot of feedback and backlash
from my family of you guys are crazy
like this is going to be really hard on
you and the kids with him gone like you
shouldn't be doing this
there's nothing going yes he has yes
everybody okay
yes we are okay um how many kids do you
have I have two okay how long has it
been so how often has he come home he
was home in March for a two-week leave
and it'll be home here the end of June
for another two weeks
and then go back for six months yes does
he have one more two week leave during
that six yes he figures it will be
somewhere around and of October November
that he would be able to come home is he
safe yes yep he's in a clinic setting he
does not leave the base he's over there
as a civilian and works in the clinic
setting as a paramedic or civilian
contractors that are in situations that
aren't always safe that's why I was
asking that's why they pay so high it's
a danger zone comes down and it's highly
inconvenience the other thing so well
the question is not what your family
thinks
I mean it's sweet that they're so
helpful but the you know helpful with
their opinions and their support and
their encouragement everything but you
know the bottom line is is you know is
that worth it to you and your kids and
your husband to suffer through this six
months to hit this goal I don't think
you're crazy I think you're doing an
extreme thing that's very difficult I
wouldn't tell you not to do it but I
wouldn't tell you absolutely you had to
do it so it's a you know it's
hard enough thing to that you're doing
that it has to be something that you the
kids and him hold hands you pray about
it you talk about it and we're going to
do this it's only six months we're going
to do this
military families do it all the time
yeah it's their job it's what they sign
up for but you know you don't have to
you're not in the military so you can
come home and make you know considerably
less than he makes there as an EMT in
Fargo or wherever you're going to live
with your move and and you'll get out of
debt the question is is it worth it to
you all to stand to accelerate this and
some families do better with stuff like
this
I personally couldn't do it because I'm
such a wuss and such a homebody I mean
it would just I I mean I have I don't
have kids at home I got two dogs and a
wife and I'm an empty nester and I can't
stand not being home so for extended
period times all of my travel is in one
two and three days spurts these days and
so I can handle that but this idea of me
being gone from sharing for six months I
I couldn't do it but that's not to say
you're wrong for doing it it's just I'm
weak in that area I can't do it I'm
where I'm wired different but there are
families that steel themselves to this
and are able to do this and it's not a
strain for them like it would be someone
else what your family's saying is is
that they don't understand how you can
do it because to them it seems so extra
such a sacrifice you know they couldn't
do it is what they're saying and so but
that doesn't mean you can't do it if you
want to do it and both of you are in I
don't think you're crazy I just think
you're doing a very hard thing and you
got to make sure it's worth it yeah is
that okay yes yes thank you so much sure
thanks for the call